um dois peculatos pessoal e quem fala é
o dark exige muito em mim jamais um foco
em vídeo mas night at freddy's 3 noite
quatro temos muito perto do fim
em resposta minc é a quinta noite pois
ainda temos a sexta ea sétima se seguir
a lógica dos outros finais e fred todos
eu não saí não vi nada sobre este jogo
quer ser surpreendido completamente bem
que eu acho que já não há sim muita
coisa que não posso surpreender
a não ser que novos eletrônicos novos de
alucinações não sair mas eles passaram
já ouviu bater no canal do 3 1 e
empataria inscrição eu faço um desenho
de e e desenhos e porque é que isto
porque o canal deu porque recentemente
fez um design dos princípios xei brutal
por isso esse pilar ainda tinham voz no
vídeo deu se gostarem de design
obviamente e isso vai passar o jogo cair
meia noite-noite 4 e o que nós vamos
fazer nesta noite pessoal basicamente
vamos fazer mais do mesmo vamos tentar
usar aquelas nossas técnicas para
afastar o spring trepp da nossa sala eo
neste caso está agora na sala nova e vou
tentar o trio então pra sala 8 mas pelo
que eu tenho jogado pessoal eu acho que
este jogo está um pouco menos assustador
do confaz night at freddy's 2001 por um
simples motivo é o champs que eles não
são assim tipton rápidos filme descrito
no ataque muito rápido um pouco lento
apesar de bizarro para caraças
ainda é um pouco lenta atacar então à
medida que não está aqui eo ainda estava
à frente do time à frente eo pocinho
preciso desligar o áudio que busca
levantar o ânimo tavana rápido rápido
vai embora vai embora amanhã
ok e como eu disse apesar de elas
estarem a eu não se sustentando com
prisão por foxwell assim ou fred porque
é um pouco lento a parceira de pensar se
muito bizarro é um pouquinho no entanto
é o que torna é menos assustador em
comparação ao fox e os outros todos
porque porque não faz nada 732 mesmo que
vocês se habituassem o sus tyova um
susto na mesma por custos eram muito
rápido e agora isso não acontece muito
por que suspira entrega para essa elite
que já é previsível sustentam em si não
mais estar muito mas vou tentar ao
máximo passar esta noite muito rápido
previsto
consegui incluir neste vídeo a noite 51
são está estragado e eu lá dentro da
inclusão tem quase certeza vou cair 4 da
manhã estamos a apostar muito bem esta
noite ainda não morremos ainda não falo
sem legenda não dar alívio passado ele
não é o fred que é por cielo seleção deu
foi por ser agora não vou preocupar
porque sou fred toca aqui outra vez e
obra
trinta e tal eu achava estreita eu acho
que a fiel à chávez malova por ser eu vi
o a passar filho da mãe
quero tocar o álbum de rap sabe tocar
aqui pelos ir embora agora tenta
explorar aquilo precisa que isso não vai
me tratar em cima isso supostamente
lógica é essa por esse meu tocou do
trecho pela preta
okay cinco da manhã para lá passar por
uma curva perto isso sim de manhã à
capital pela pista o que é igual diz que
está aqui vai lá passa agora passa para
seu time completar passe por favor seja
amanhã conseguir passar qual noite 4
completa para esse pessoal fazem um
vídeo e pegue uma sandes de pão com
manteiga e edson se o fox e desta vez
que eu tinha me esqueci no time ganhe eu
disse que já não viu mais eletrônicos
mas ainda havia que o fox se o nosso
amigo fox estou sequer propor eu sei que
vou morrer e obviamente é por isso que
eu já tô sic o tipo e entendendo como
por onde eu vá eu vá apanhar ela vai
mandar eu já saía o meu destino a alguns
de vocês também disseram que o portugal
e matamos para arrancar um passo do
corpo a cada um e juntar tudo e fazer os
pretos e eu concordo com a teoria porque
visto o sprinter é perfeito de farias
várias partes do corpo de um animador
ônix e visto que o papagaio está a matar
e deixar que alguma espécie de huacho
que se tire é que está certa
ok ninguém completo acabamos por morrer
e obviamente noite cinco esta vai ser
mais difícil suposto mim é o última
noite e depois temos mais duas que são
tipos noite discreta já não quer saber
da cal
normalmente o zé manel não dá pistas é
absolutamente nenhum mas nada falou o
edital tem que sobreviver e que acender
as luzes
e não quer ser e houve 21 são agora você
já ouviu nem a quem está aqui dentro da
inflação agora e nesta e leste o sub
faixa silence lin
assim o são paulo foi muito muito foi
muito longe o jato todo suado meu bar
conhecido luz passar duas noites no
invisível e só me embora lá pessoal pega
um pão com manteiga que eu sei que você
já comeram em si e sem demora noite
cinco à frente vamos lá ver ventilação
que eu acho que houve um passo um passo
do satanás aqui dentro
não não está tranquilo também virou e
rock usei muitas agulhas não tudo o que
de mau futebol fifa manda tudo era
tributo ou e books álvarez paz perder
tempo enquanto matéria vamos rasgar a
cueca nato tem que ser mais rápida
dentro da pulsão bicho poio do demônio
parte que o bio meu time não é só
conferir o que está estragado agora nada
o fred vai parecer vai aparecer agora a
usiminas on the world to contar com isso
e eu estava esperando dos 33.000 alguém
está na ventilação que obi
só uma coisa estragada alguma não duas
alguma tudo estragado gestos lord
incluindo portanto pensei agora caiu
freire vai perceber que nava já voltou a
escalar o burnley ela voltar
o brasil tocava o áudio e vai provar
outra vez um time em cada um
aí eu posso tocar nela não vai achar que
vamos estar lá mas só eu vou passar a
lei é impossível admitiu que eu to
fazendo errado
ok pessoal fim da manhã eu tive que
muito tempo para conseguir ficar até as
5 da manhã os pernambucanos agora que
quando começou a falar eu precisei de um
concentrado para caraças por conseguir
agora chegar até às cinco da manhã
eu espero conseguir passar esta noite
porque o jato que há muito tempo a
tentar meu seio tasser tipo o desespero
total
está a correr muito bem pelo menos ainda
não viu sempre trago uma única vez o que
é o sam andar aqui na ventilação agora
não está aprendendo não está o meu eu
via tudo tudo tudo siga manhã a pneu
aproxima chega agora diga nunca ficar
parceiro eo via porcaria de uma imagem
no computador meu eu vi uma imagem
bizarra que nunca tinha estado também é
e nunca teve tão contente por ter as
três da manhã este brutal consegui
passar a noite cinco vamos forma enigma
e eu tive que muito tempo só lá serena
teve muito tempo tive que me concentrar
para caraças de quem eu sou agora quem o
personagem de palhaço lá vamos nós ser
mortos pelo zelo 10 chutou foco de novo
agora faz nem aí ela agora fosse para lá
eu vou apanhar agora não sei quem eu sou
mas aparentemente time do domingo vamos
apanhar não é impossível é possível
apanhar ar e eu possuiu os prep
só porque morri não morreu
o cae então eu diria estava certa
o por aí uma dúzia de estudos
bedi em dengue que o fim do formato foi
de 3 1 final mal ou nightmare a extra o
que é isso meu animatronics minigames
joan busquets chips e hoje eu vim com
tudo aqui meu esta ética que foi como
estou agora nunca tinha apanhado de
chicanes do jogo
ok o fred já apanhei e os é palhaço eu
não ponho os apoiasse não percebo porquê
mas não apanhei escaleno nightmare
escalar eu só preciso nightmare já sabem
pessoal se quiserem ver um vídeo da
noite nightmare deixou a equipe foi o
grito
espero que tenha um estado fiquem bem
até a próxima e
o futuro